allora, elezioni europee 2000 e 24
in Italia capiamo come si fa
allora? innanzitutto, quando si vota? si VA a votare
l'otto e il 9 giugno.
nel 2000 e 24
è un weekend, sono sabato e domenica,
quindi cercate di non prendere troppi impegni.
Chi è che VA a votare?
in Italia? votano
tutte le persone che hanno compiuto
almeno diciott'anni
entro la data delle lezioni.
come si vota? beh, se siete in Italia
basta andare direttamente AI seggi. semplice.
se invece siete italiani
ma siete residenti all'estero,
in un altro paese europeo,
basta essere iscritti
all'aire e potete votare anche nel vostro paese
di residenza. infine, perché si vota?
beh, perché dipende da noi e da Chi vota il
futuro del nostro pianeta.